- [Narrator] It's happened to you.
You're shopping for shoes.
You see some.
Click on them.
But decide, not now.
Not before payday.
Not when you're trying
to be better with money.
Not today, Satan!
So, you click over to
Facebook, trying to run away
from said shoes, and there they are!
Haunting you.
How
does Facebook know you so well?
It's not in your head.
Facebook ads target you,
and this info isn't hidden.
If you visit the "How ads
work on Facebook" page
in Facebook's help
center, you see there are
four categories where
Facebook gets info on you
for advertising.
Number one, information
you share on Facebook.
Things you comment on,
pages and posts you Like,
and any ads you click on on Facebook.
Yup, that makes sense.
Number two, other
information about you from
your Facebook account.
You know, this includes
stuff in the About section.
Okay, that makes sense.
Number three, information
advertisers and our marketing
partners share with us.
What?
What does that mean?
Well.
Facebook advertisers
share their info about you
with Facebook, and in turn Facebook helps
them improve their ad audience.
Visit the "Your ad
preferences" page to see
who Facebook thinks you
are and what they're
sharing with marketers.
Wait, one of my interests is blanket?
And then lastly, the fourth category is
your activity on websites
and apps off of Facebook.
Simple enough, just
gathering info on mostly
everything you click on.
NBD. Moving on.
But seriously, pages that
have Like or Share buttons
notify Facebook when users load the page.
And a code called Facebook
Pixel can be used by
web publishers and Facebook
alike to track site visitors
that are also Facebook users
like Stick-Lady Sally here.
This feature allows both
Facebook and advertisers to
track data like when Sally
views an advertisers product
and when she adds an
advertisers product to her cart.
Also, Facebook like many
companies, receives information
from data collection
firms that can be used
to target ads to users.
So, they may know you have those
odd magazine subscriptions.
Girls and Corpses.
Ew.
And retailers have the
option to share loyalty card
information with Facebook
as part of an ad campaign,
hypothetically allowing
Facebook to know what
people purchase at stores IRL.
We can see how much they
know if we try to place
an ad with Facebook.
So, lets spread the word
about my new hypothetical
restaurant, Puddin's.
All Puddin, all the time.
I can choose to place
my ad to be seen by just
LA-living, 35-year-old
moms, that have an interest
in desserts and make a good deal of money.
Cause this is expensive pudding.
Yeah, it can be that specific because they
could know that much info about you.
But despite how personal it might feel,
you're just data for them to track,
and that tracking can
be good for businesses
whose marketing dollars
can potentially go further.
Super cool for my start-up, Puddin's.
But maybe you really aren't into online
interest-based advertising.
All you wanna do is
see if your friends saw
you did that amazing hike this morning
where you snapped the perfect pic,
not get roped into purchases.
Well, you can choose not
to be shown certain ads,
or opt out of ads by specific
advertisers completely.
And Facebook's data providers,
third parties that gather
info, have opt-out forms
that users can submit.
But whether you keep
personalized ads or opt-out,
you can't stop ads because
ads are needed to help
keep Facebook free.
Well, time to get back to puddin-makin.
I got a lot of moms waiting for me.
(playful music)